[Music]
only his body of work this split he is
probably the worst ad carry in the
league right now which is so inexcusable
from from a player whoa doublelift get
hot out there flash follow from a pro
boo Oh baby that's the setup for me
personally I feel like I should have put
myself at a higher standard or something
but pretty much just didn't care I feel
pretty good cuz we're actually in a
position and I haven't been in a bad
position like that in a long time so if
you just look at the way we're playing
we're not even really a top team anymore
so I think it's really cool I think I
need the stress in my life a bit to feel
motivated
I don't think double-up gives a [ __ ] at
the start of the season if I was playing
myself I would have [ __ ] punched
myself in the face already like you need
to start taking it more seriously or
you're gonna get benched coach's long me
that was benched and I would be able to
fight for my spot like maybe later in
the split felissa playoffs so I was like
okay that sucks being around the team
while they were screaming and I wanted
to play the cochinita decided like it's
not a good time for you to play I feel
like it's healthy having a player that
cares in the fact that doublelift like
literally wet on camera and admitted
that he just didn't care about the
season at the beginning winning the
split doesn't matter to me that much
anymore
because I've won so many times like when
somebody when your player says that I
feel like that just like okay
let's um let somebody else play that
actually wants to play when team played
without me and one Mattacks fool I felt
like oh [ __ ] now I really really want to
play
and sucks you get benched and yeah it's
inside I've just been pretty pissed off
okay they're going over the net editor
are going for a back George they make
the turret is very low they're going
after it spends not the arrows revenge
is coming playoff chances sayonara to
Team Liquid that is the end of their
spring split the era has ended and the
casket has been closed on both liquid
Team Liquid are out of playoff
contention they've bombed out of the
spring split in what's now considered
the biggest downfall in LCS history but
to fully understand why this is such a
big failure we have to go back to last
year they are the only team to lift the
trophy back to back to back to back
[Applause]
America produced Team Liquid ended 2019
by solidifying themselves as the
greatest LCS team ever becoming the
first team to win four back-to-back
titles they even made it to the finals
of msi beating defending world champions
Invictus gaming in the semi-finals and a
huge part of their success was double it
the most successful player in the
history of LCS in the beginning I was
looking for status I was looking for
people to recognize me as a great player
people recognized me Zerg a player now I
was looking for a lot of titles now I
have the most titles like I was looking
for a lot of things and I got them all
and now I did supposed to basic form I'm
just looking for a competition he's won
seven out of the last eight LCS splits
and the only reason he doesn't have
eight he took a split off but despite
all of those LCS titles doublelift could
never transition his success to world
it's not acceptable that I go to Worlds
every year as the first seed and I [ __ ]
the bed and I just I never perform and
my team never makes any grooves and yeah
I mean Jesus I didn't think I was gonna
get emotional actually oh that's alright
but like I like it's been eight years
and I can't do this thing but I'm just
I'm never gonna give up so that's what I
want to say 2019 Worlds was no different
with liquid and double lifts failing to
make it out of groups for another year
so the team made a controversial Rasta
move dropping their veteran jungler
xmithie in favor of fanatics peroxide
hey what's up guys it's Steve co-ceo for
Team Liquid I've got a really important
announcement for you so the rumors about
Broxton and me disliking each other and
having a poor relationship it just needs
to stop a world where Team Liquid and
brock's ax aren't on the same team just
simply doesn't exist
so welcome to the team the change was
supposed to help liquid become a true
global contender instead it marked the
beginning of the end for this domestic
dynasty with rocks of stuck and visa
purgatory liquid was forced to start the
season without their new jungler and the
results were not ready the community's
perception early on was hey these are
problems that are all dénia fixed by
week three people were starting to come
around so I think but some of us already
knew internally even if we weren't able
to say some of it which was teams really
doesn't seem to be approaching the
season with a winning mindset as you
might say and so it's no surprise that
they're not winning and the guy taking
the brunt of the team's criticism was
doubling doublelift has played four
games of setup lost them all and then
the other two games he had one game on a
Philly O's where they just smashed fly
quest mm-hmm and then the other game was
on Zion I died twice before level four
when he knew at least started topside
and he got flashed on by a bio frost
Leona doublelift underperforming was bad
enough but his attitude is really what
got the community fired up for me
personally I feel like I should have put
myself at a higher standard or something
but pretty much just didn't care and
then now that we're behind I think I
care a lot more now that we have the
rest of the split to go like nine
something more games like that the other
50% I feel pretty good because we're
actually in a shitty position and I
haven't been in a bad position like that
in a long time so if you just look at
the way we're playing we're not even
really a top team anymore so I think
it's really cool I think I need this
stress in my life a bit to feel
motivated and when Brock saw finally
made it to na he was not the savior
everyone hoped he was I felt a lot of
pressure coming here everyone has been
saying
once I arrived here everything not only
should change well actually would change
and I would magically just turn things
around and start waiting it that's a lot
of pressure to heaven on my shoulders
like not only am i replacing smithy but
I'm also expected to turn everything
around and turn the team in so you know
a winning team something needed to
change and that change came in the bot
lane I mean look I feel like it's
healthy having a player that cares in
even if even if you say like in a vacuum
tactical is not as skilled as doublelift
the fact that double if like literally
wet on Cameron admitted that he just
didn't care about the season at the
beginning like it's so much better to
have a player like tactical who's gonna
be giving his all compared to like
somebody like double its who's like Oh
spring food doesn't really matter I
don't really care like I'm just focusing
on other stuff like winning the split
doesn't matter to me that much anymore
because I've won so many times like when
somebody when your player says that I
feel like that's just like okay let
somebody else play that actually wants
to play what started as a week off due
to laryngitis turned into double lifts
being fully benched coaches told me that
I was benched and I would be able to
fight for my spot like maybe later in
the split opposed to the playoffs so I
was like okay that sucks being around
the team while they were screaming and I
wanted to play but like they wouldn't
you know like
the country decided like Sun a good time
for you to play it was me me like kind
of not happy one game in two double if
being benched and liquid realized that a
rookie ad carry wasn't gonna be their
Savior because is good player and then
he have a little talent but I don't know
maybe he getting Fischer and he's lucky
right his young player maybe looks like
he losing confess a little bit sometime
and then he is too quiet during a game
his good player
what I'm not sure about his mental now
this is the part of the video where
liquid gets it together double if makes
his return to MVP form and the team
makes a miracle runs of the playoffs
except none of that happened and Team
Liquid became the first defending LCS
champions to miss the postseason both
guitar going it with the net answer are
going for a backdoor they make the
turret is very low they're going after
it spins got the arrows revenge is
coming
shut down team liquid playoff chances
and slam them into the ground and that's
how it ends this is hat extends this
level of performance drop-off is
unprecedented in the LCS this team was
built to compete internationally four of
the five players on Team Liquid were
voted all-pro last summer
they've taken games off world-class
teams like IG and g2 now there's a
second last place team in the LCS in a
matter of three months Team Liquid has
gone from the top of na to the dumpster
I kept getting asked flowers when are
you gonna say TL is dead and I said that
I'm not gonna say it until it officially
happens and this game was why like you
got to see the fight at the very last
moment even if they lost control their
own destiny and needed a bunch of other
luck to get them into a point where they
could have forced a four-way tie for
sixth this game against cloud nine was
everything they had left in the tank c9
should feel accomplished that they
finished him sayonara to Team Liquid
that is the end of the
spring split they are officially
eliminated now a 7-eleven collapse but
liquids here isn't over
come summer it'll be on double if to
prove that he's not washed that he can
still be the best and that he can take
Team Liquid back to the top of na thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]